cette énième conférence de presse
sanitaires étaient particulièrement
attendus et l'effort demandé aux
habitants de seize départements de
l'hexagone est une nouvelle fois
conséquent un confinement d'au moins
quatre semaines a été annoncée par le
premier ministre jean castex
il s'agit des huit départements d'île de
france
les cinq départements des hauts de
france et puis les alpes maritimes la
seine maritime et l'eure dans ses seize
départements de nouvelles mesures de
freinage massive de l'épidémie
interviendront à compter de ce vendredi
soir minuit et pour quatre semaines
seuls les commerces qui vendent des
biens dits de première nécessité
resteront ouverts
objectif réduire davantage les contacts
dans les lieux clos a poursuivi le chef
du gouvernement
cette notion de biens de première
nécessité sera étendue aux livres et à
la musique ce qui permettra aux
libraires ou disquaires de rester
ouverts par souci d'équité les
restrictions de vente s'appliqueront aux
mêmes produits qu'ils savent qu'ils
soient vendus dans un rayon de grandes
surfaces un commerce spécialisé ou un
petit commerce de centre ville
dans le détail c'est un confinement aux
conditions multiples qui est décrétée
écoles et collèges restent ouverts les
lycées poursuivre avec un rythme en 2011
quant aux universités elles continueront
d'accueillir partiellement les étudiants
les déplacements entre régions seront à
nouveau interdite tandis que le
couvre-feu lui sera décalée à 19 heures
à partir de ce samedi
l'exécutif qui demande par ailleurs aux
entreprises d'appliquer le télétravail
au moins quatre jours par semaine
outre ces mesures de confinement la
france compte plus que jamais sur sa
stratégie vaccinale pour enrayer cette
spirale négative
et dans ce cadre les injections du
controversé vaccin d'astrazeneca
reprennent dès ce vendredi dans le pays
à commencer par jean castex lui même